16 años y una nueva búsqueda ilusionante
la petición de las autoridades alemanas
Este martes la policía portuguesa retomó
en la presa de silves al sur del país
las pesquisas de madeleine la menor
británica ha desaparecida en 2007
mientras pasaba sus vacaciones de verano
en una localidad de la costa lusa Aunque
el embalse ya se rastreó en 2008 sin
éxito ahora un ex detective que jugó un
papel central en las investigaciones
comentó que hay motivos para tener doble
Esperanza
una Es que la policía alemana sigue al
ritmo no se quita la presión sigue
invirtiendo recursos y número dos en
algún momento tiene que haber un gran
Avance en este caso en algún momento la
suerte tiene que cambiar
Alemania identificó formalmente a su
conciudano Christian broker como
sospechoso oficial de la desaparición de
la menor
la fiscalía de está investigando a un
ciudadano Alemán de 43 años sospechoso
asesinato asumimos que la está muerta
el presunto autor ha negado cualquier
vinculación con el caso y aunque no está
condenado por ello se encuentra entre
rejas por abuso a otros menores tráfico
de drogas y la violación a una mujer de
72 años en la misma zona donde se perdió
el rastro de macán pese a lo mediático
del caso y las investigaciones conjuntas
entre Lisboa Londres y Berlín desde 2007
no ha habido avances significativos
sobre el paradero de la niña que
desapareció en una casa estival mientras
sus padres cenaban con unos amigos en un
bar cercano a la residencia